las vegas original arts and crafts show
is back the harvest festival who is
sponsoring this next segment is here
with us today and they're back this
weekend the brand new expo at the world
market brenda thank you so much for
joining us oh my goodness it's so great
to be here it's harvest festival time
it's harvest festival time tell everyone
about it who's never been to harvest
festival we took off last year we are
back bigger than ever what can everyone
expect well we are the biggest we are
the most unique and it is a show that
has been traveling the western united
states for 47 years
37 of those in las vegas so you're just
not going to want to miss it it's like a
magical marketplace you go in and
there's all kinds of artisans and
crafters and candy and potpourri and
everything you're going to want for
one-stop shopping for the holidays you
shop till you drop literally
indoors which is great so don't worry
about the heat
parking oh we have just the best news we
are in our brand new location we are at
the expo at world market center and we
have lots and lots of free covered
parking just take an elevator go right
into the hall it's convenient it's cool
and you're not going to want to miss it
i i certainly don't want to miss it now
talk to me about there's i know there's
a charity time you're always giving back
to our community what's the charity
tie-in purchase festival really believes
in being community responsible so for
over 20 years we have supported safe
nest and we filled their pantry up for a
whole year they really missed it last
year so we need everybody to pitch in
and bring non-perishables canned food
hygiene products and when you bring it
to safeness that'll be right outside the
box office they'll give you a coupon for
two dollars off so let's get together
and fill their pantry up once again
you're saving money and helping out a
great cause as well now uh al you're one
of the vendors out there tell me more
about your company that's gonna be out
there well we make a trivet hot pad okay
that opens into a basket right now it's
opened
if we close it down
you can take a hot pot off the stove wow
out of the oven up to 500 degrees wow
right on there and you this is something
you hand make yeah wow yes and that's
what i love about harvest festival
people like al are going to be out there
who i mean you made this with your own
hands uh these are local you're a local
person in las vegas local residents
selling their goods it's such a cool
event yeah american arts and crafts at
its finest we actually are a juried show
so everyone in our show
has been juried and everything is
handcrafted and handmade and so it
starts tomorrow though right it does at
10 o'clock friday saturday and sunday
one ticket for the whole weekend kids 12
and under free
great kid zone strolling entertainment
we'll see you there oh i'm going to be
out there absolutely so just real quick
on the kid zone what's happening in the
kids zone oh we have kel portland that's
doing this great environmental family
maze we have we have make it and take it
crafts but because of the way things are
we also have take it and make it so if
you want to stop by you don't want your
kids sitting down for too long of a time
we'll be handing you things so that you
can do all kinds of harvest festival
crafts at home and you mentioned too
there's traveling entertainment we have
strolling entertainment and so it will
be very festive and and just add to the
mood of our harvest festival original
art craft show marketplace brenda i've
known you since 1996 and every year
you're putting on huge amazing local
events and we love you for that thank
you so much well it's just so great to
see you and thank you for having us
please it's our pleasure las vegas
harvest festival original art and craft
show it's happening it starts tomorrow
the 10th through the 12th at the all new
expo at world market center bring a can
of non-expired food or paper products
for safeness and receive two dollars off
the price of admission